you may want to get a different spot to
write this though this is what mrs.
Lee's been anticipating before and so
we're going to deal with that like
promised with first moves but then we're
gonna go beyond that
I just wanted to beyond a shadow of a
doubt because you actually have to be
very careful with these things that that
what we think is true is true and why
okay so pens down for a minute
just have a look up if you recall one of
the things that we used to prove all of
this stuff like how to deal with powers
was we used these are these expansions
do you remember that right we use these
expansions now these are important to
come back to because you have to be very
careful with saying oh this is true
therefore I can conclude stuff from them
for instance we said that a to the power
of M minus B the power of n equals and
then we had an e minus B to start just
like we always did and then you've got
this gross a n minus 1 B sorry a the N
minus 2 B blah blah blah we had all of
that stuff in there right now just think
about this for a second if I think about
this guy right because this I can write
as an index right it would be X to what
power now this would be a negative 1
right I used to get told like change the
sign cross the line so it becomes like
this is underneath so it's sort of a
negative power but it's just a cute
rhyme there's no reason why it's true
it's just ah
there it is okay now let's figure out
what this means for this guy right can I
think about what a to the minus 1 plus B
to the minus 1 would be equal to and
quite quickly you realize wait a second
I'm in Kansas anymore right if I say
starts add a minus B right and then I
start to say okay well let's now
establish the pattern right within this
case what's my end it's negative 1 right
so what will the first term be if n is
negative 1 the first one should be
negative 2 right and then what will the
next term thing and of a negative I'm
meant to keep going down right keep
going down so the next one down is
negative 3 and then you get a B for some
reason and then what's the next one down
and of the negative for and then you get
another B now hold on a second where was
I supposed to end I was supposed to end
all of my a is end up like going down
down down down boom they're gone and
then you end up with B's but hold on
these these A's are not going anywhere
these just keep on going down and down
and down so in fact you get a problem
here because in fact we know for a start
this thing is 1 over a plus 1 over B
that's what it is by definition that's
not how it factorizes right so you have
to think that's why we come back to
first principles first principles this
is foundation it's like should it work
well first principles we know it works
beyond the shadow it out what will
happen when we try it out so I've gone
ahead excuse me I've gone ahead and I've
substituted the first line there's the
difference question can you see this is
f of X plus h here's f of X so far so
good ok now this actually you know
marvelously is not that hard to deal
with when you see two fractions and you
have to add or subtract them what is
your instinct when you see like 1/3
minus 1/5 what would you do comment
denoted thank you we got to get them
talk in the same language so what would
be a helpful common denominator for
these guys now if I had plus h here
that'll be nice then they're both plus h
but the problem is for example if I said
oh look let's make this over 5 let's do
such add 2 right
but that's not how fractions work
because you can't just add 2 up there
1/3 1/3 the last I checked is not 3/5
right so instead of adding stuff to
denote numerators and doughnuts I've got
a multiplier right so I will do
something like cross multiplication here
I'm going to multiply this fraction by X
over X so that leaves me with x over X X
plus h I'm gonna leave that factorize
you'll see why in a second and then
instead of multiplying this by X over X
I'm gonna multiply by X plus h over X
plus h because I haven't changed the
fraction so that leaves me with X plus h
over the same denominator that was the
whole point right
common denominator is that ok and all of
that is over H ok I know it looks gross
but that's ok we've seen things go gross
and then they pan out at the end ok so
let's have a look
limit comes out the front common
denominators that's fine so what happens
when I
X take away X so how many X's are left
on the numerator they're gone but then
there's a minus H minus H then this
denominator is X X plus h that whole
thing is on the top and then as we've
seen before if you did it right you can
see there's some kids thing you can do
right what can I cancel this H and this
edge so far so good
all right let's see what do we got here
so limit H approaches zero if you cancel
your H what does your numerator now
become - weren't very good that's sign
doesn't disappear and then our
denominator it's this x times X plus h
business right
why don't I any longer have to write
this guy yeah we can't so it's divided
by one which doesn't do anything okay
now here's our lovely spot where before
I could not put H equal zero because
then you're divided by zero that's bad
but I have a look at this guy
can't I put in H equals 0 what will
happen you get minus 1 over this is just
X and then this becomes X plus 0 right
so in fact this is just the X can you
simplify this for me minus 1 over x
squared now let's think about this let's
go back to our rule our magical rule
right we said what if we wrote it like
this right well if this is f of X what
does f dash X become if you think about
the rule that we established what
happens to the power minus-1 comes out
the front and then what happens to the
power
it reduces by 1 that's really sneaky
it's a negative so when you reduce it by
1 negative 1 turns into negative 2 just
look at that closely look at that does
that look familiar it does right now the
cherry on top for me is when you think
about what does it all look like can we
get the lights for this mist thank you
okay
so here's 1 over X this is the function
where I think it's not that bad
everything this is 1 over X our familiar
old hyper bar okay now we just
determined that the derivative
the gradient function apparently is what
- 1 over minus 1 over x squared let's
have a look at that guy there is right
there think about this with me here's
the blue line
it's the gradient function of the red
line the first thing I notice is the
blue lines are always negative why is
the blue line always below the axis
always negative hmm think think the
gradient of the green e of the red line
right from here to here how would you
describe that gradient in words it's
shallow but it's decreasing it's
negative what about what about over here
it's like steeper but still decreasing
and then here it's just decreasing what
about over over on this side oh look
this is also decreasing so the first
thing is the red graph even though it's
it's like located in up-and-down spots
gradient wise wise they're doing and the
answer is always decreasing everywhere
okay and then the other thing I noticed
is see this blue line right it just sort
of like drops off a cliff right it gets
it's like a little bit negative here and
then it gets real negative what does
that mean yeah this red line very good
it's um it's dropping off at an
increasing rate it's getting steeper and
steeper steeper what about what about
over here the gradient function starts
really really negative because this guy
is dropping like a rock you see that and
then it's like I still stay negative but
I'm not I'm not hates negative I'm just
like a little bit negative what does
that mean over here
it's just sort of gently going down
right it's gently going down never turns
around though why doesn't it ever turn
because it's an asymptote see this
gradient function it gets close to zero
but it never actually gets to zero so
yeah
which point in talking about this point
here ah good question what does that
mean you can actually read the values
off here right yeah yeah this is for one
negative negative one negative one so
actually if I drew a tangent right here
it would have an angle of inclination of
45 degrees downwards